[Music]
[Music]
so Miguel Santos TV planning here at MIT
my pleasure to welcome you all this
videos evening actually it's great that
surveys became I want to thank Mark like
you care very Olympics were here sitting
there you go very quick for doing this
actually for coming with the idea it
went out of its way to the old issues of
equity I think from that period on with
the whole issue of increasing diversity
on our campus has been something that's
that's you know constantly discussed it
may seem that we are verified but the
truth
most of the numbers of students from all
over the world from all different
ethnicities increasing by the years
we've also been making an incredibly
large effort to try and bring in a more
diverse faculty the truth is we do bring
in you know quite large numbers of of
black faculty and some disciplines but
we have a few lousy job or somehow
keeping them and getting them through
the process
the tenure and this is something we're
very acutely aware of I've been here for
three years now and we have somebody
sitting on Academic Council that meets
every week who who actually is in charge
of some of these issues particularly
when we say underrepresented minorities
which really includes women still today
although I think the issues have been on
the process of being so we and our
school also have a committee that deals
with diversity which markets being an
elite player for for quite a time and we
are the first school of F MIT to require
somebody whose full-time job it is to be
the manager of diversity equipment
and where are you who dictates that up
this is Robert Chapman
[Applause]
Robin Robin is charged with helping us
get the best database we can in the
world she's here to work with other
Diversity Committee she's here to work
with the student bodies and I felt that
if we the ways were talking about it
that didn't actually have someone who
looked after Robin and we were very
fortunate to find her she's got a PhD
from MIT and he you see is by the media
that so she knew that my TIGI do our
culture and in general you know listen
if she could have a Amundsen I'm dying
to do this here she is and I hope you
have a chance to speak with her and I so
that's my good sir I would like to do
now attend to what main element Weiss
who received a PhD from University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign and she's
now a professor of optical history at
Tulane University and somehow survived
the flood and is there actively trying
to keep the school together in public
school his received many awards for her
work and she studies the history of
african-american architects and one of
one of the people she faces in on his
road to graduate
very early on he was the first black to
graduate with a degree in architecture
who went on then to have a glorious
career and it was very intuitive so we
thought it was appropriate to start with
you them and the drawings as you
probably would realize now of focus
pieces we have in our collection and
it's outside
[Applause]
I think Santos the news is better than
that wherever Taylor is my team's first
black friendship not just the school of
architecture concept right yeah and he's
also the first professional training
African American architect was the first
who's trained in school rather than
office trend I think that's very
significant I'm very grateful to my
teeth for inviting me here
I want very very much for karate teacher
realize the historical journey you have
Robert Mueller was the first epidemic a
trend in African architect and nineties
first black graduate class of 1892 he
spent his career as a teacher
administrator and designer and Booker T
Washington's to speak Tuskegee normal
and industrial Institute a residential
vocational high school in east central
Alabama
he designed around 40 brick buildings
there at elsewhere plus an unknown
number of wooden ones it was Taylor's
good fortune oh I completely forgot we
come with slugs it's my responsibility
yes there we go Arians arias in 1906 it
was Taylor's good fortune to be born in
Wilmington North Carolina which is
across the first part town with before
the Civil War many many excellent black
builders and some builder architects
both slaves and free during
Reconstruction Wilmington even had black
residents and city council it was
ideally close to being something
approaching an integrated city except of
course of many of you know it all
erupted it and reversed in 1898 was took
all women to massacre but we're not
going there Taylor wasn't there at that
time Robert Taylor's father was
illiterate
the allahö slave whose own typically
slave whose own white father and master
allowed him the personal freedom so that
he could prosper as a merchant carpenter
and contractor this is the
family home which was built by his
father henry taylor only how we have our
taylor gatto
standing on the right the photographs
he's always on the edge of the group and
I wanted to linger on this to point out
the little boy who's Taylor's son but
instead he worked as a builder for a
year or two and then went north and then
an MIT
Taylor's MIT years where success as
clarence williams has shown he was at or
near the top of his class and awarded a
scholarship for the second two years of
his four-year course while taylor's
architecture peers in course or were
distinctly yankee his larger institute
class would have been international a
description of the class of the previous
year put it this way
praise of niche 67% were like
complexions 33% dark 11% were I glasses
and one who's colorblind and fifty
percent thought they had mustaches there
are clearly been among the latter fifty
percent as well as 33 percent the
academic schedule was
with too many horses by modern standards
and such particular architecture of
course for horses but memory drawings
and the orders we've done on the
blackboard
- and then specified scale course for
have and Bart bass pedagogy with history
lectures with parents lungs weekly
supervised trips to the Museum of Fine
Arts precedence research and library
monthly design problems and juried
reviews as one student wag put where is
an all well conducted abattoirs the
custom is to slaughter before rendering
the process here is rehearsing all the
work is rendered first and slaughtered
afterwards Taylor also learned from MIT
stone construction mainly the purpose
design architecture building that was
occupied the year after he left the
Pierce building was a six-story
industrial structure with stone and
brick mason facade that freely mentions
classical medieval and industrial
elements in a way to suggest that I
think suggest aspects of what Taylor
would eventually apply to speedy
taylor's fine pieces and ideal to own
during the lifetime of practice was a
home for Civil War veterans from both
north and south I need to interject a
little bit parenthetically right here
Taylor's not was not just tears enough
MIT so only contribution to MIT a
engineering student named Harry D Taylor
didn't graduate was probably in Rome at
about this time arrived at us to be
shortly after
and stayed there for his entire career
this is something when students can take
on Taylor was corresponding with Booker
T Washington's summer after graduation
while he was building mechanic at Hotel
McBride suspended Washington was
recruiting University educated
african-american the sports escapee he
also wanted a black architect to design
the expanding campus and to prove the
races ability to a watching world
Washington would have seen the young
Richard Morris hunt three large
buildings go up at Hampton Institute
architects Washington learn can best
articulate and institutions purposes too
and then went to Cleveland to begin
practice but soon accepted Washington's
Lord arriving in Tuskegee
in November 1890 to his first Alabama
completion was a frame industries
building at another school and he
probably also do the cottage plans and
elevations that Washington gave out
firms who attended the Institute's have
self-help conferences Tuskegee was
always about outreach its mission a vast
rural hinterland with hundreds of
thousands of the very very poor usually
landless farmers sharecroppers tenant
farmers brick buildings at Tuskegee
began with son was first called science
and then Thrasher Hall and then the
chapel and enslaved the chapel
particularly like this photograph it's
very hard to put photographs inside the
chapel but these are not students these
are the farmers this is the farmers
conference and when you think about how
these people from the dregs of the
bottom of society were invited into
with me the vastest building they
probably could ever enter in our lives
Most Wanted building and the building
was electrically lettuce the first
electric they were building in the
county I think that we always begin to
understand the meaning and significance
of this yellow effect the only known
architect makes Oh Chapel the Oaks which
is Booker T Washington's home boys
trades building and Huntington home they
would have also been innumerable wooden
cottages barns rural schools and other
service structures teaching however was
Taylor's heaviest test there is a bench
since students had to draw everything
they were to make every train steam
Fidan plumbing shoe making tin smithing
tailoring carriage building our wheel
riding started with plans and elevations
because drawing promoted modern
industrial processes and was thought
consequently genuine intellectual growth
drawing hit a racial dimension because
of truck planning or as they thought
termed it the executive thinking that
slave the artisans who supposedly worked
only under strict supervision were
thought to have lacked tailor also
developed events throwing horses for the
building trades and a pre-professional
postgraduate architecture certificate
that he awarded to a wheel riding major
the future architect William Sidney
Pitman tusky husky Keys army of drones
students probably overwhelmed the
teacher contributing to his 1899
decision to return to Cleveland to took
two instructors to replace him in
Cleveland Taylor worked for a white
architect with some rockefeller
commissions and then on his own but he
kept Tuskegee s climate for Cleveland he
did the girls industries building here
it is more recently but
now which is called Dorothy home the
lincoln gates and that's actually
dorothy call and the chapel behind it
in fact they all have the same donors
phelps dope sisters in new york who gave
the gates and dorothy hall and the
chapel the boys and girls bath houses
here's the boys bath house we work on a
project too long and to find the date
was lucky you a shot because it's since
been demolished and
Cummington more memorial academic
building which i'm going to show you in
color because tragically that tune is
gone and burned taylor returned to
Tuskegee around 19 to but now as
director of voice industries beheaded 20
to 30 trades divisions each with its own
shop classroom and faculty as an
academic administrator he was
responsible for hundreds of students who
were enrolled in a complicated
curriculum that interlocked with the
academic program and with much greater
difficulty with income generating
industrial production Tuskegee depended
on such commercial enterprises as
printings implement repairs or Brittany
in for income and in Washington's theory
to intolerance we know now of course how
tragically such folks turned sour
elsewhere that Washington and his
successors actually made it work for
Macon County Tuskegee remained an oasis
of safety in the closest front Tuskegee
also production projected across a
utopian image to the northern
philanthropists that they were
supporting because it fed clothed and
sheltered itself with its own skilled
hands while preparing students to go out
and do the same for others because
Tuskegee constructed its own buildings
it also fell to Taylor to coordinate
Junius jobs among the various shops seem
to it that material foreman and student
workers were smoothly deployed and the
buildings came in on time and within
budget he was also responsible for
campus infrastructure the endless
drainage and sanitation problems power
and water supply walkways and roots and
the minutia of individual office and
classroom needs hanging a picture or
cutting a doorway or giving the decree
Phoebe washed out of a bathroom it is
hard to imagine how he did it all while
simultaneously running all of the
industrial and divisions and after hours
designing buildings he seems to have
credited his education for his building
to adult juggle multiple tasks but he
also rested by reading nurturing a
special fondness for Shakespeare
tailor's Architecture from 19 1 until
1915 when Washington died included still
more brick buildings such as the
Carnegie Library which is still alive in
the know think of least on the outside
not the inside Rockefeller Hall the
floor Emory dormitories the office
building douglasville it's an entrance
into an auditorium sort of taking
advantage of the slope but the arch
Hartwell apart Tamsin Paul whoops
Douglas all white hole this is white
hole tantum hall
I skipped Andrew a hospital for various
reasons but there is a hospital in here
the veterinary hospital veterinary
hospital and the new laundry pause for
me he also designed Carnegie libraries
for Wiley University in Texas Marshall
Texas and living somehow is my favorite
last Livingstone college in Salisbury
North Carolina he did not design the
largest building of the period Tompkins
dining hall we're seeing it from the
readership and see how big a complex
this one is perhaps and this is my
speculation perhaps because he did not
trust himself to work at a scale that
demanded steel framing a white
courthouse experience courthouse
designer did it but our guy represented
the Institute and the architect to each
other
shake washington's programming and
planning decisions argued the project
before the trustees and after the white
guy's untimely death mid-construction
figured out how to set the dome on wood
trusses
that's it before the dome dome on wood
trusses without having post up the
dining rooms spatial unity that
Washington very badly won tailors
buildings revealed his mit-trained
Bozarth roots even when there are no
classical obvious classical elements on
display as there are in the new laundry
they are characterized by triadic mess
and this is what you're supposed to
secure with emphasized centers that are
embraced by flanking units that lend a
strong sense of horizontality to the
mass they have finely tuned proportions
syncopated arrangements of window shapes
and sizes
this is the stair hall being picked out
from the back of a dormitory this is the
case where there's a real skinflint
donor and I think I have the front of it
Taylor one of the two story broader
veranda that would have more kind of
play and an impact centralizing impact
and the donor was too cheap to allow it
so Tim was secure University got his
jollies by doing the back like that
didn't cost a cent
I would hope
occasional bursts of wit
the syncopated windows occasional bursts
of whip catch the rhythmic play on the
second level there is something really
demands that but I think the rhythm in
the entire facade you can't see me
Jenica some suggest that somebody very
clever is doing marvelous stuff with
many minimal means and contrasts between
sharp cut window voids and the wall
plans that display tuskegee x' with
richly textured homemade bricks attest
these bricks if almost a kind of icon of
the institution I mean I try not to go
on and on about that just leaving it
there I don't know Washington talks
about when you get discouraged think
about the first brick making we almost
failed but we carried on and go we built
with a built build build on our school a
few structures do break into the formal
rhetoric of projecting columns under
entablatures and pediments Latin and
Greek in the words Washington would use
when he wanted to put down when he
considered useless pretentiousness
Washington once told the students that
john d rockefeller could given tuskegee
a plane but elegantly proportioned
during touring this is not it nest up
here who had given a plane let's leave
it on this a plane but elegantly
proportioned dormitory always use words
of one syllable rather than two or two
rather than three rockefeller used Noah
Latin or Greek quotes and he was the
richest man in the world full-blown
classicism on early twentieth-century
Negro buildings also raises thorny
critical questions the classical portico
on tusky East Carnegie Library this is
what we want now here's the Tuscany's
carnegie mother prepared the same
year that the new Alabama Constitution
stripped most black people of the vote
White's were using classical imagery on
similar institutions including
courthouses at the same time that this
was built and at the same time that they
were sanctioning violence to enforce
increasing Jim Crow restrictions running
through the south during the 1920s
Taylor partnered with a younger Carnegie
trained black architect Louis personally
on still more Tuskegee buildings the
Chambliss children's house was the
center of it right there
sage Hall James Hall and a quad for the
new college department with a larger
science building and a new library
building here are much larger facilities
and more normative and perhaps less
interesting to us now you have to get
into at least some of them this is Logan
Hall which actually combines a gym and
an artist where him in one space with a
stage at the end and underneath the
stage is swimming pool this became a
neighborhood cultural center with
first-run movies and famous musicians
who would travel through the white town
white tsking could ever afford anything
like this Tuscany was really trying to
over the town itself Taylor and
personally also did substantial
structures elsewhere this is at Selma
University in Selma and I can't show you
and it's just as well cuz everything's
pretty ugly that's a seven sixty four
thousand square foot seven story colored
Masonic Temple come office building that
was also the social center of
Birmingham's black elite through the age
of seven segregation important bill that
I has
decent photograph of it most Taylor and
persley buildings were contracted to the
black-owned Wyndham brothers firm in
Birmingham a company in which Taylor was
invested Taylor seems to have inherited
his father's business acumen and had
many investments and little businesses
on the side by which I wished I knew no
more
he sent five children through college
throughout his life trailers personal
reticence attacked served the cause of
interracial diplomacy who traveled often
to New York to meet with trustees or
donors in 1923 he was the ranking
administrator on campus when the Ku Klux
Klan paraded through the Klan was trying
to intimidate the Institute into
accepting white medical staffing for the
adjacent Veterans Administration
Hospital for black patients Taylor
stared the clown down while Huskies
principal Robert Rissa Moton and the
NAACP were negotiating the issue in
Washington DC
Tuskegee won Taylor helped investigate
the refugee camps for african-americans
displaced by the 1927 Mississippi River
Club concluding that those who which
blacks shared in the management were far
better than those in which they did not
his diplomatic skills joined his
educational vision and design talents in
1929 when he traveled to Liberia to help
found the Booker Washington Institute
Taylor analyzed Liberia's agricultural
and industrial potential outlined as to
curriculum to support it advised on
governance and staffing sketched the
campus plan and designed a few buildings
he then capped the trip and his career
with a grand tour of Europe in 1932 the
64 year old and I don't know they'd be
64 their butts just deal with it the 64
year old Robert our challenge suffered a
massive heart attack he's visiting his
in Chicago he retired shortly thereafter
returning to Wilmington so he would not
embarrass his successor
there he lived a gentleman's life
there's the town house I don't know that
he did it I think probably he did not
thing we need to learn about that one
with a town house and the waterside
retreat about 20 miles away he had a car
and a driver so he could travel between
them
Taylor had another ten years and used
them well as an admired townsman whose
word mattered he served as the first
african-american on the board of a black
state college and he worked with a
powerful white man as it happened and
this I think is amazing a leader of the
1898 massacre to try from New Deal
funding to help local farmers getting
better status to get better community
for local farmers and recreational
facilities for black teenagers Taylor
wanted to return to Liberia to continue
that work but his health did not permit
it he died in the Tuskegee Chapel in
1942 while on a visit he had just
pronounced the building his masterpiece
Taylor left her record of kindness and
generosity along with the becoming
modesty about his own achievements he
was a lovely man to know his daughter
Nora told me she never would have known
about this MIT degree had not others
told her when I complained to her
grandniece it was hard to find out about
him she replied and with some asperity I
thought that he was too busy helping
humanity to keep up records about
himself Taylor believed in work for its
own satisfaction and attention to detail
financial prudence religion for the
solace that can bring one keeping one's
word and service finally when I asked
his son if Taylor thought he was more an
educator or an architect Edward Taylor
split the difference
Robert are tailored thought of himself
as an educator and here the Paulus was
deliberate but he knew that he was an
architect thank you
[Applause]
I thought before I introduce our keynote
to give you some background revisions
for this conference
two years ago committee was created
under Stanford Anderson of the
Department of Architecture to study the
situation that under represented
minorities well there are many parts of
that city and many of them which let me
discuss perhaps later on in the
conference there tomorrow
there was one element to say to say the
least that were shocking we discovered
that we had graduated only six African
Americans at the a marked level in the
past nine years versus 2210 non African
Americans so that's roughly three
African Americans for every thousand on
African Americans
meaning that MIT had done a terrible job
recognizing the problem much less
providing any leadership in it perhaps
it was because the department is so
international with people and languages
from all over the world filling out
corridors that we didn't notice I don't
know
but what I do know is that the failure
to recognize this low graduation rate
was a mistake on our part and there's no
sense to sugarcoat it now
the graph I show here is roughly the
graduations in the last 100 years
whereas women have risen remarkably in
the last 30 years and constitute here at
MIT as in most places in the u.s. 50
percent of the student body
the story of african-american City was
not so rosy nor even so promising we
graduated no more african-americans
today than we did in the late 1950s in
fact given the bump at the late 60s
there you can sort of see there's a
little bit goes up in the 1960s and
early 70s in which there are several
alumni here in the audience we can say
that we're doing perhaps even worse than
we did in the 1960s after you know 50
years now I don't know of other schools
are facing similar situations I do
suspect so but that doesn't change the
message that we have for you here today
which is that the first step to change
is certainly to recognize our own
failures and this we have to do quite
publicly it is the first step to
rebuilding trust
part of the reason for this conference
is therefore to learn how to speak of
the problem and it's not necessarily an
easy task I for one had to learn how to
do it myself
and it began when I talked with David
sledge was coming in from Georgia stucks
America I think there is was this
investor somewhat five years ago and I
asked him one day out of the blue what I
was like to be the only black student in
the department and he answered that it
was the same anyone here had asked him
that question at MIT I didn't really
understand the depth of what he had
meant at first but it began to slowly
sink in
so I thank him for that conversation and
for the conversations we've had since I
learned from Larry SAS who teaches here
in the department about issues of
tokenism and questions of mentoring and
how in some sense the whole issue of
African Americans is a question
discourse and I learned from
conversations with Darren Hendricks
who's also sitting somewhere here up
there with conversations about him and
it was these conversations that led us
to the conference itself when we sat
around and we said well we have to do
more than just talk about it we have to
bring in people to have an open and
frank discussions about teaching
administration about architecture about
the profession and to learn to see the
problem not just as an african-american
issue but as a broad cultural issue in
the field of architecture and
architectural education or there's all
of us why it's a black mass following
the International should have a claim
there's no magic bullet that is
affordable the issue is complex and
multifaceted but ten years from now we
will be in a better position than we are
today that which I guarantee you ten
years from now we hope that MIT will no
longer be seen as an example of the
problem but as an example of the
solution the chairman of the department
of architecture jeong-ho Chang
somewhere over there Dean Ando Santos
Provost at Kolbert and others and MIT
his administration have committed a my
team to understanding the problem and
they're working with us on this issue so
these two notes which are the noble
Odyssey and of upins I would like to
introduce our keynote speaker Ted thanks
mark is now nationally and
internationally for his commitment to
the questions of Architects education
and as a spokesperson of
african-american cost is the director of
the Boston Architectural College located
just across the river of the Back Bay
not that he didn't get stuck into the
back into the river walking over here is
the same function from Museum of quarry
southern decorative arts a National
Science Foundation who serves ahead of
port aboard of the magazine of Boston
architecture of our colossal as mark
also serves as a trustee to numerous
arts related foundations including
wasn't Institute of Contemporary Art and
Seema Fine Arts
[Applause]
well there's no point how do I advance
this
well excuse me while we do some
technology I've served as president of
the Association of collegiate schools of
architecture over the course of the past
year and in that capacity I've had an
opportunity to get to about 70 of the
accredited architecture programs around
the country of which there are now
neither 116 or 117 we'll talk about that
differential towards the end of my
comments and one thing that's quite
clear is that the kinds of issues that
we try to address here hopefully this
booming will go away in terms of
microphone other kinds of issues that
we're being called upon to address here
are obviously not distinct to MIT I
taught here in the Department of Urban
Studies and planning
a number of years ago back in the late
70s at a point in time when a lot of
these issues were being raised a lot of
us talked about them at the time while I
was trying to do something but the
issues have not gone away as I think
everyone knows I'm going to talk a
little bit about race and architecture
I'm going to talk a little bit about
architectural education as a broader
context for trying to understand some of
the issues that we need to address we're
going to be specific about developing
some solutions where the issue doesn't
race in architecture and I also have to
talk just a little bit about the
practices of architecture in the
profession thereof as I think many of
you know that BAC is a practice-based
learning institution so all of our
graduates have to work three years in
firms before they can graduate and as a
consequence I get to see a lot of what's
going on in firms these days and what's
going on in firms to a large extent I
think replicates or echoes what has gone
on in schools I should also note that
ordinarily when I've been called upon
over the course of the past year to try
to discuss these issues a conversation
is with American Institute of
architecture groups or various licensing
groups such as in carb which means that
ordinarily I'm speaking to audiences
that are 98 percent white and usually
about 70 percent male and ordinarily
those groups are groups that have to be
persuaded that some form of diversity is
a good thing that they need to think
about an address because by and large if
there is any American profession that is
not in the way with the kind of benign
neglect of diversifying itself over the
course of the last thirty years its
architecture law addressed these same
issues thirty years ago medicine
addressed these same issues
business schools address these same
issues it belts solutions and when you
go into those kinds of schools you see a
very different student and faculty
makeup than one sees in design schools
so change is possible but it's only
possible in the context of a broader
cultural and professional set of changes
and whatever MIT elects to do will be
very important and useful because I
might be as clearly viewed as leadership
as leader within the field of
architectural education but you're also
taking on an entire profession which has
elected to a very large extent to ignore
these issues completely there are about
a hundred thousand licensed architects
in the United States
moment that's a convenient number
because it helps to get the percentages
very easily it's probably closer right
now to about 102 thousand of that
hundred thousand that's worth we've been
able to tell 1571 or african-american
and of that hundred thousand one hundred
eighty six for african-american women I
have a hundred thousand the upcoming
issue of our architect magazine as far
as I know is doing a cover story I don't
know if it's out yet okay I haven't seen
that but this conference was recorded in
an architectural record and architect
magazine has taken note the magazine's
took know that this thirty years ago too
and they didn't do much about it
the hope is that at this point these
numbers will change the Cambridge School
of Design that I'm referring to actually
I have a more updated number it's not
thirty six I think it's actually forty
eight that that well-known Cambridge
School of Design graduated over the last
thirty five or forty years that number
shows up shortly in the entire
Commonwealth of Massachusetts are twenty
nine licensed African American
architects one J Lee just came online
but then we lost one through death a
couple of months ago so the numbers have
not changed twenty nine out of about
three thousand
this slide I normally have to put up for
my white audiences here presumably the
fact that you're here in the midst of a
blizzard northeastern means that you get
it
this jump twice diversity is important
because the market that we serve has
become diversified it is global and as
long as the American architecture
profession purports to be in a position
to understand the cultural organ on ik
aesthetic values of most of the world
and is a profession that remains with
only one and a half percent
african-american participation in that
profession we can't really hold
ourselves out to be the kind of
profession that can really serve the
world very effectively the total number
of Architects in the United States has
increased very slightly over the course
of the last decade or so there's a
slight dip which was brought on in part
by a recession in the early 90s that
doesn't show up here but the actual
numbers of architects in the United
States have not changed dramatically
is that why is this important question
this is a profession that tends
particularly when one focuses on the
effects of modernism on architectural
education and the like to hold out that
it's possible to plant the same kind of
building anywhere in the world but in
fact there are many of us who believe
that that does a disservice to the
clients in those various parts of the
world and what we found is that
certainly from a marketing point of view
and this is what I always have to
explain to firm principles being a more
diverse firm opens more opportunities
for that firm it creates a better kind
of and richer dialogue within the firm
as more people of
diverse backgrounds bring different
kinds of perspectives I remember when I
was at Yale for example and we would ask
to design a public housing development
some of my classmates actually planted a
baby grand piano in the the drawings
that they did an Isaac kid who grew up
in the projects knew that that was
ridiculous but as of the time that I was
in school those students had no idea of
the appropriateness of that plus
diversity is the right thing for us to
do the other thing that's interesting is
that there is more of a need for
architects in the world today than at
any time in our history but the
profession itself is not growing as such
so to a large extent whether it's
because of the objections that many
practitioners raised that engineers and
developers and builders are taking away
all of the work of Architects that's one
issue but the larger issue is the
profession itself has not embraced what
its responsibility is to really provide
service to all of the people in the
world who need architects so in a funny
but not so funny way this profession is
the only major profession that I found
in the United States that in proportion
to the world need is actually shrinking
and it's becoming a niche profession
that celebrates a certain kind of
architecture but not in fact the kind of
architecture that needs to be done and
when I've done this presentation to
student groups which again are primarily
bright and young and full of enthusiasm
really terrific kids and all that sort
of stuff the first thing I have to point
out to them is that in 25 years their
clients will not look like what they
look like and that they need to get used
to that idea and figure out how to
adjust to that it's an interesting slide
in that it talks about the percentages
when we look at American professions
where do architects and in relation to
other kinds
professions 129,000 figure is is a
somewhat soft figure in fact a census
data the most recent census data argue
that there are almost two hundred
thousand people in the United States who
declare themselves to be architects only
half of those are licensed so somewhere
between a hundred thousand and two
hundred thousand there is a number of
people who are practicing this
profession that number is not important
in and of itself what's important is
that in relation to other professions
basically there are ten accountants for
every architect in the United States
there are five doctors for every
architect there are more than 10
engineers for every architect so we
start with a small number of individuals
who are actually practicing this
profession and there's always been
discussion about why it is that
african-americans and other people of
color don't go into this field and often
it's not the argument is put forward
that you know the smart black guy isn't
gonna choose to become an architect
because he can't make as much money it's
going to become a lawyer instead like I
became a lawyer advocate becoming an
architect but the reality of the
circumstance is that in comparison with
other professions architects are in a
living wage and what we've discovered
from some of the polling that we did
some of the studies that the American
Institute of Architects undertook two
years ago what we discovered is that in
fact the people go into architects you
don't go into architecture for the money
none of us do that we go into because we
like to make stuff we're builders we're
makers of things we're designers of
things and that the economic incentives
in and of themselves are not sufficient
disincentives for people to go into this
field indeed when one looks at the AIA
his own figures in terms of what it is
that architects earn in the United
States one would have to argue that in
fact
these are living wages and I know that
our BAC graduates when they come out of
school if they know a little bit of
rebek are starting in the fifty to fifty
thousand dollar fifty or fifty-five
thousand dollar range which is not a bad
starting salary I mean it takes you a
long time to get there but it's hardly a
poverty wage and that in fact principals
of major firms in this country owners
are earning six figures and some good
six figures so the argument that's often
put forward that people of color don't
go into this field because they can't
earn enough money in it it's pretty much
a bogus argument and then when people
say that to me I also flip the argument
around and then ask well the people of
color are too smart to go into this
low-paying field what's wrong with all
the white men who do are they all really
coming from sort of white shoe
backgrounds the answer's no they're not
so the economic side of all of this is
bogus because there's so much text here
I've added some slides of some of the
architects we ought to think about those
people who have in fact constituted the
foundation of black architecture in this
century so we know that there are a
hundred thousand architects and we're
going to get into some more detail here
around that hopefully will be discussed
in further detail tomorrow
there are about 33,000 folks in our
architecture schools we'll get to that
number at a moment but of the 200,000
people who declared themselves to be
architects roughly 20 percent of women a
little bit less than three percent are
african-american nearly six percent or
either Hispanic or Latino it start to
count Hispanics and Latinos because of
self-declaration issues roughly 6
percent Asian 3 percent say that they
are American Indian so technically
that's among those who declare
themselves to be architects about 15
percent are so-called people of color
an end card the licensing body at this
point reports about a hundred 1000
licensed architects part of the
difficulty that we have in this
profession is that there's no central
database from which one can draw
information that tells you what the real
number is because in fact and carb the
national licensing body draws its
information by calling around to all of
the state licensing bodies and since
many architects are registered in more
more than one state there isn't a way at
this moment of getting one definitive
number on the total number of licensed
architects but of the 80,000 members of
the American Institute of Architects
interestingly only 12% of women despite
the fact that for at least 10 12 15
years half of the students in all of our
architecture programs in the country
have been women only 12 percent of the
members of the American Institute of
Architects of women 2 percent are
Hispanic or Latino 1 and a half percent
are black 3% Asian we also did some
surveys a couple of years ago now of
people who are practicing but not
members of the American Institute of
Architects and interestingly of those
numbers about 10% of women where you can
see the numbers for yourself
architecture school graduates are
interesting as well the total number of
architecture schools students in the
country has varied minimally in the last
20 years it's varied from about a low of
31 thousand to a high of about 33 34
thousand the actual number of graduates
in any given year is about 3000 from all
of our programs across the United States
and in comparison with who is in higher
education overall and I have several
layers of data here more than half of
all of the students enrolled in higher
ed in the United States are now women a
little bit less than 10 percent are
african-american about 6 percent Latino
about 6 percent Asian in masters
programs interestingly nearly 60 percent
are women about 7 percent 78 percent
african-american a little over 4 percent
are Hispanic almost 5 percent are Asian
and there's among those getting master's
degrees in this country only about 2% of
all master's degrees that are awarded in
the country are awarded in architecture
the vast majority are in business
engineering law healthcare this does not
count education fields where there are
huge numbers of individuals getting EB
DS and PhDs but as among traditionally
defined professional degrees
architecture amounts to only 2% of all
of the degrees that are awarded in any
given year so of our 33 almost 34,000
architecture students a little bit less
than a third would be considered
minority and as you break it down in
terms of
of programs and these numbers start to
get particularly interesting for us in
pre-professional degrees there were only
116 african-american graduates of
pre-professional degrees in 2003 which
was most recent year we had data on this
in our B Ark programs there were only
116 graduates from B art programs
nationally in 2003 in our master's
programs there were only 40 graduates of
M Ark programs in 2003 who were African
American and now we get to the really
hard stuff which is to say where are
those African Americans coming from and
it turns out to 37% according to data
that's been developed by Dennis Mann and
Brad grant through the University of
Cincinnati 37 percent of all African
American architects hold at least one
degree from an historically by collagen
University that means that of the
hundred and seventeen programs that are
now accredited in the country the seven
HBCUs are turning out 37 percent or
roughly five percent of all of the
programs in the country and turning out
nearly forty percent of the African
American graduates so what are those
schools and again this is from this was
actually updated just about six months
ago
Howard it's turned out the largest
number followed by Hampton Tuskegee
Southern down in Baton Rouge Florida A&M
which is not an accredited program
Prairie View in Texas Tennessee State
which is not an accredited program
Morgan State it's also interesting to
see when these programs were accredited
in relation to how many graduates have
come out of them and then what about the
rest of us what about the so-called
majority schools and here interestingly
I've only listed the schools that had
can say that they have 20 or
more licensed african-american graduates
Columbia's at the top CCNY robada
Harvard that's the 48 number that we've
come upon Berkeley Cornell Michigan MIT
reports a total of 30 tech Detroit Mercy
NYIT my alma mater Yale and IIT there
are some interesting patterns here in
terms of urban rural East Coast central
Chicago Berkeley none of us have done
well is the bottom line back in 1968
Whitney Young then head of the National
Urban League made a speech to the
American Institute of Architects
National Convention he chastised the
profession because in 1968 only 1% of
all the licensed architects in the
United States were African American
today we've gotten it up to one and a
half percent
we are almost certainly the worst
profession in the United States having
made any kind of change over the last 40
years and I hate making reference to
this particular image but it's true if
we were to triple the number of African
Americans who graduated from our
programs over the next decade we'd still
only be up around 10% and the fact of
the matter is most of our programs in
incarnating were close to tripling the
numbers of our graduates so the fact of
the matter is that there is every
probability that unless we take radical
steps someone else
15 years from now will stand at this
platform and will be able to use exactly
the same slides with minor updates
one of the issues that always comes up
is around what happens after folks
graduate how long does it take to get
through the architectural registration
exam and to what extent is there an
impact a differential impact on people
of color in terms of getting to
licensure once they've graduated and the
reality is that we didn't find a
substantial difference although what we
did find is that in significant numbers
which presumably will be talked about
tomorrow there is a higher probability
that a graduate of an HBCU will opt not
to go through the abuse of guard to work
for a firm in the areas where most of
the HBCUs are located for a 3-year
internship to then take a licensing exam
when they can go to work for HUD or the
Defense Department or the Corps of
Engineers doing architectural work at a
higher starting salary never have to get
a license have a lifetime of job
security and never go into traditional
private practice and indeed that appears
to account to a very large extent for
what happens to graduates of
african-american HBCU programs that is
they choose the path that is the most
logical path and they are not to go into
private practice and the whole question
of internship raises one other very
difficult issue within the context of
the profession as we move forward I
don't know if any of you were
participants in the American Institute
of architecture students annual
convention which occurred this year here
in Boston over at the Sheraton about
1,100 students came in and BAC and
Wentworth the Co hosted those students
and one of the presentations there was
from a firm in India an outsourcing firm
the kind of firm that architecture
firms don't like to talk about a lot
because of all the liability issues that
are inherent in sending your work to
India overnight to have your production
drawings darlin until very recently the
whole business of outsourcing within the
profession was simply something that no
one talked about at all but all those
firms are now out of the closet and that
we managed to get a presentation from
one of those firms at the aia meeting in
boston and the firm principal said look
i have the ability to employ a thousand
people in my firm in india or in similar
firms in Pakistan or China or Egypt you
do your work here during the day and
send your work to me electronically
overnight my thousand people will turn
around your work more proficiently then
can an intern in your office because
they're well-versed in Revit they know
all of the latest software and they're
doing this kind of work for firms all
over the world we can get the word back
to you the next morning and one-fifth
the cost and so students who erect this
conference
at the end of the presentation went up
to some of the people from n Carbon said
we'll wait a minute if the work that we
as interns used to be able to do in
order to develop the skill sets
necessary to take an exam can now be
done in India and one-fifth the cost
what kind of work are we as interns
going to be doing if you hire us and
none of the folks from endcard had an
answer for that because it is becoming
increasingly clear that the kind of work
that architecture school graduates have
been doing in firms is now being
outsourced for much less money and more
proficiently we asked a series of
questions through the AIA as to what
were the key reasons for people not
practicing and we did some comparative
analyses of these I can't go into all
the detail
year for those of you who want to see
that detail we've kind of posted it on
the BAC website it was commissioned work
that was done for the AIA and then the
AIA didn't want to release the study but
since I chaired the Diversity Committee
and worked with the firm that did the
study I thought I had some proprietary
right to hang on to the results of the
study so for any of you who really want
to see the full 120 page study you can
go to our website and it's quietly
posted there but what it does indicate
is that many of the reasons for folks
not practicing in terms of differentials
visas the race and gender have nothing
to do with inability to do the work on
willingness to do the work or even the
usual Bugaboo that's mentioned for women
families that in fact most of the people
graduate from school have every
intention of practicing in some way
shape or form and that the usual stuff
of gee I can't find enough people
because they don't want to do this kind
of work is a lie what are the normal
institutional impediments that we have
come upon through our studies in terms
of entry into the profession I might as
well use the word someone else will at
some point if I don't racism is out
there it's alive and well in the
profession there's a lot of great talk
about yes we're open and yes we want to
hire everyone but racism is evident in
many of the firm's
the patronage and class system for of
turning for obtaining private work
drives a lot of what determines who goes
into work and who can survive in this
field because we all know the clients
are private clients in particular are
individuals who one meets through social
networks and the like and if you're not
a part of that social network you tend
not to see them I go to many many many
events in the Greater Boston area put on
by my friends and colleagues and the
architectural profession and
variably I am the only person of color
there even today lack of role models
lack of access to capital markets in
order to get the work done and
interestingly and this came out of a
study that was done as much in Australia
where some polling was done a number of
years ago around racial and gender
differences in terms of coming into the
profession turns out that significant
proportions of women and people of color
would decide to go into this field have
an orientation towards doing work that
would be considered community based work
it's not the kind of work that's
celebrated by and large in our major
publications or even in our schools or
in our awards patterns we celebrate the
high profile individual corporate work
or the individual home we tend not to
celebrate the work of the great
community-based architecture designs of
YMCA and as a result what tends to
happen within the context of studio
culture and other culture is that we
celebrate exactly the kind of work which
is not the kind of work that most women
and people of color come into this field
to do and so there's not much of an
incentive as among students were
studying this to feel as though the kind
of work that we might want to do is the
kind of work that's likely to be
celebrated let me also know again in the
context of the wider profession what the
key issues are that deeds and these are
American Dean's view as the key issues
that are coming up in terms of both
education and what's happening in
practice at this moment and these are
interesting issues in a disciplinary
design effective design and
communication finally there's a
recognition that many many architects
are wonderful designers but totally
unable to express themselves in any form
other than graphically they can't write
they can't speak they can't present and
architecture firms or increasingly say
we'd like to have some people here who
know how
present they work as well as producing
it sustainability of course
technological growth human health and
safety and issues around licensure and
let me just say that the licensure issue
was viewed as as somewhat abstract for
me until last week when I found out that
the Canadian equivalent of end car of
our American licensing group has just
collapsed the four major provinces that
represent about three-quarters of all of
the architects in Canada have decided to
withdraw their support from the Canadian
equivalent of endcard and in doing that
they've decided that they're now going
to write their own provincial exams and
I shared that information when I got it
with the endcard folks just two or three
days ago and fill it out yeah and they
hadn't heard it yet but clearly that's
gonna have some ripples and
repercussions for things like
International reciprocity of licensure
and the ability to work across national
borders generally and the fact that
certain American states like California
and Texas have been moving in that
direction anyway so the question is what
are we educating our students for if
we're thinking that they're going to
become licensed at some point if the
very structure of licensure seems to be
collapsing and that's something that
remains to be answered bill that is
building information modeling for those
of you who aren't in the middle of it
and performance-based software
integration the whole set of issues that
comes up around embedded intelligence in
design software suburban and urban
growth increasing globalization design
build processes project delivery talent
shortages we'll come to in just a moment
but I have to say that having visited
nearly 70 programs in the United States
most of our schools are not talking
about them at all we do talk about
growth issues we do talk about
globalization but when it's hard pressed
to go to an architecture school that's
parking
design build processes they're out there
but few in number and I've raised one
other issue and that is to say that as
of next fall there'll be a major
conference these occurs every five or
six years during which the very
structure of architectural education is
going to be reassessed and perhaps
revised and as we've started talking
about all of this stuff I remind folks
that the last time we had one of these
conversations which was only four or
five years ago
things like BIM and integrated practice
and Revit and outsourcing and work
sharing were not discussed at all and
yet we came up with a set of guidelines
what architectural accreditation should
be without reference to any of these
things so whatever we talk about next
year which will set the standard for
what architectural education will be
until 2015 is almost certain to be a
discussion about a number of things
which none of us have begun to think
about in terms of what design education
will be and how that will also be
affected by cultural racial and gender
factors I always like to ask what are
the skills that we really bring to the
architectural process what is the value
added did any architecture brings to a
client how does one change is slide if
it doesn't want to change and that is
ultimately knowledge of clients and the
ability to listen which is not something
we generally teach in school needs
interpretation for our clients which
some of us teach problem analysis and
problem solving the ability to innovate
which MIT has always been spectacularly
good at I always loved teaching here
anytime I walked out into a corridor I
felt as though between the students and
faculty we were on
cutting edge of knowledge in the
universe and I know that that continues
so that's not an issue here and project
management
and I have to go through this list
because as we talk about globalization
and its and its impact on education
generally there is a poll I think they
finally wrapped it up that was done by
the European equivalent of the
Association of American schools of
architecture and what they asked was
what is it that firms in Europe are
looking for in design school graduates
and it turns out that what they found is
very similar to what the American
Institute of Architects is also found in
its own polling number 10 on the list is
ability to develop transdisciplinary
understanding 9 is the ability to learn
to learn eight is the ability to
evaluate evidence 7 7 on the list is
design skill 6 is the ability to apply
knowledge that one has obtained in
school to practice five is the ability
to create designs that satisfy aesthetic
and technical requirements for his
ability to work with a high degree of
both autonomy and collaboratively 3 is
the ability to work in interdisciplinary
teams to interesting or interestingly
are the personal and social skills in
expression that enable one to interact
with a client and number one has nothing
to do with design as we traditionally
understand it number one is the ability
to have critical thinking and analytical
skills
sorry to skip over robert taylor but you
heard about him we also need to think
about what it is that comes out of our
schools because there's a pattern
tomorrow that will be talking about
education and how we go about assessing
quality in the schools obviously great
faculty and resources innovative
academic depth again not an issue here
designed within rigorous curriculum not
an issue here excellent students not an
issue here but there are a bunch of
things that throughout this
contextualizing of what it is we're
training for they're a bunch of things
that we have to ask why is it that
people of color have been excluded from
all of this learning what's going on
what is the problem here and we've
listed some of the impediments and we
also know that there have been many
initiatives that have been put in place
over the course of the last 3040 years
Ford Foundation invested millions of
dollars in conjunction with the American
Institute of Architects starting in the
late 60s and into the early 70s in
supporting scholarships I can look
around this room I will do this because
I have to do this periodically are there
any people in this room who know anyone
who got one of those Ford AIA grants who
became an architect no the point is that
millions have been invested in efforts
and initiatives that no one bothered to
track the effectiveness of so we did a
lot of feel-good things and those
feel-good things got us from 1 percent
to one and a half percent and that
clearly hasn't been good enough
so the recommendations that have been
put forward to try to change all of this
include increasing public awareness of
what architecture is I mean let's face
it most people have no idea what we do
ensuring adequate resources that usually
mean scholarships but it also means
other kinds of resources increasing the
visibility of architects of color hence
the images I've included here and
expanding the nature and diversity of
leaders within the profession growing
people and putting them out front so the
more people know about the work of a Mel
Mitchell or Robert Cole's improving
licensure rates and developing mentoring
programs and part of what we realized is
that there are not if they're only 1571
african-american architects in the
United States they can't all be mentors
as such so it means we've got to find
different kinds of mentors to step out I
am NOT for example a licensed architect
and yet I've won the AIAS Whitney Young
Award for my work in this field because
I believe in architecture there are many
other people like myself who believe in
architecture who are not licensed
architects who are prepared to try to
work to change the numbers we have to be
called upon but the profession tends to
have so much hubris and insularity that
it tends not to look to us very often
for what it is we're prepared to try to
contribute requiring diversity training
within our firms certainly but
ordinarily we try to start with our
local AIA components where people just
sort of take it for granted that they're
so smart and capable and tolerant and
outgoing that in fact they don't need to
understand what it is they're doing in
their firms like the firm principal who
came to me once and made a suggestion as
to what color of collie
he would like me to like to see me
showing up at so she
Levin Swift as recently as four months
ago people just don't get it
and then finally a set of more specific
recommendations that were working to
develop that hopefully people will talk
about here and elsewhere one of the
things we realize is that by and large
the folks who go into this field have
been exposed to it fairly early on
without regard to race or gender someone
in the family was involved in
construction or had a hardware store or
took him to Home Depot a lot to do minor
repairs around the house it's something
people are familiar with and we need to
start earlier than high school to begin
to introduce folks to things
corporate involvement of design supply
companies it struck me that in many
respects the easiest way to do outreach
would be to set up a card table out in
front of a Home Depot or Lowe's in a
community of color and have your schools
sit there and say this is what it is to
be an architect we want you to think
about coming into this recruiting dart
design school faculty of color from
fields other than from the 1571 licensed
architects they can't maintain practices
at the same time that they're in a
classroom teaching you're asking us to
do too much giving voice to students of
color and design schools I see one of my
recent graduates here brandy Brooks who
now runs the Community Design Center of
Boston and when she was in school we saw
to it that people knew who she was and
all of our schools have to do that
promoting a broad diversity of opinions
within private design firms which
doesn't happen a lot these days
monitor the government and foundation
diversity programs that exist at this
moment to raise the question of whether
they just feel-good efforts or something
that really has an effect and
acknowledge and support the cultural
globalization of design practice and
that means recognizing that while our
schools and our
firms are not necessarily up to speed
with the diversity of design the reality
is practices and finally there is a
major effort that's being made at this
moment finally it's among the
architectural organizations to do what
has happened in law and medicine for the
last thirty years and that is to develop
systematic data tracking so that one
knows who's enrolled in our schools what
programs they're in who graduates who
goes into IDP who takes the a re who
becomes licensed where at this moment
again there's no centralized data source
that enables us to know all of that and
literally within the last few weeks the
collateral organizations that oversee
architecture and architectural education
have finally begun to ask those
questions and to develop a unified data
tracking system and there are a bunch of
questions that we hope that this data
tracking system will finally help us to
answer
so thanks oh yeah I'm into the global
economy too and I didn't get to print
all of these out but I'll see to it that
we get these until about five or eight
years ago there were not a lot of useful
sources of information on any of this
but the numbers have grown fairly
significantly in the last couple of
years and since we're in an academic
environment here are some good
references for you including malleus
book and a couple of others that my
folks were here so I'll say one last
thing which is in most respects the
hardest thing to say because you're not
supposed to know this 37% of our
african-american architects come from
HBCUs for the first time ever our
accrediting agency has had to make the
difficult choice to dis accredit one of
our hundred seventeen programs because
of the weak performance of that school I
know because of my position that that
school has received the letter and that
the faculty at that school are now
meeting with their administrators to try
to figure out what should happen because
there are only seven of those schools so
I can't tell you who the school is
because it's not appropriate I will say
that to the extent that any one of our
HBCUs fails then we have a major problem
in terms of increasing diversity within
the profession and what is for me most
poignant and ironic is that that school
that has lost its accreditation is one
of the schools that Robert Taylor had
the most contact with
now all of us as was the case at Tulane
and in New Orleans in the Gulf region
all of us as schools figured out how to
come together after Katrina to provide
support for faculty and students who ran
the risk of having their academic
careers fundamentally disrupted in the
post between an eighth era and it was as
a result of things that all of our
schools did still to earn at Tulane and
at other schools in that area we're able
to complete their studies and graduate
because the rest of us came together to
help out I would submit to you that over
the course of the next day as you have
your conversations one of the things you
need to think about is how we here in
this room and in other schools that are
doing well will have to come together
literally over the course of the next
two to three months to provide some aid
and support for one of our schools where
because of the lack of accreditation
students who graduated last year and
students who are graduating this year
will not be eligible to take a licensing
exam because they will have graduated
from a non navigated school so if we're
going to talk about doing anything let
us talk about the help that we need to
provide to those schools and students
who are most in need and with that you
have an overview and let's have a great
conference
[Applause]
go to bed you did you just made
something to get a chance to talk about
tomorrow because so the fundamental
issues as to why that schools fail isn't
isn't anything you might attend again it
goes to the part of some dishes
[Applause]
our circles really really talk about
relishes appropriate venue or not you
know what we try to do when when we find
out these kinds of things is to make
sure that there are appropriate offline
venues for these conversations and I
would anticipate that that over the
course of the next day or so there will
be a number of appropriate offline
venues where this can be discussed here
but my experience is such that so much
of the work is in our profession is tied
to a tradition that a gentleman's
practice so many of my colleagues
learned I mean I learned about
architecture because my mother used to
drive us around his kids to look at how
and that's how so but it was not because
of anything
in the culture that supported me that
the person who built our house was a
black architect and builders not
registered in the state of Florida when
he built the president of the community
clientele today and as I was growing up
most of the architects that I knew who
were successful developed that success
through a clientele that was government
community based some churches most of
the architects that I know who got their
starts that their starts in the social
fabric that I feel very strongly that
the schools have a role but that role is
very very limited in the sense that from
a practice point of view the ability for
us to begin to strengthen the social
fabric in this talk about that more
aggressively and how we begin to get
people to think about in our own
communities being more aggressive about
doing that it's where it's at I don't
think the problems of race are gonna be
solved because white people decide to do
the right thing I think it's going to be
solvent of white people understand that
this culture will not sustain itself
without functioning in a way that
embraces all of us and it's not going to
be solved because black people did
pressure on white B it's going to get
solved because black people
resently and creatively about how to
provide a social structure to build on
and be helpful in that regard lathy said
when you are budget artwork is my name
is Curtis David summit of a registered
architect but I've made a choice to be
an architect on the client side and I
work with Smithsonian building new
builders how we build is what informs
our school I don't think that schools
inform the process school ought to be
reflections of whether what the
community demands and needs and that's
what's important coming to school and if
the schools have a role today in this
transition is to raise that question and
truck and challenge and brain activate
to the table in a real meaningful one
thing I'll say about that is that it's
been interesting to me that more of that
consciousness has emerged from the
students themselves than for most of our
faculties